last september governor ron desantis
stepped in to help
florida residents who were facing absurd
coveted penalties
all outstanding fines and penalties
that have been applied against
individuals are suspended i think we
need to get away from trying to
penalize people for social distancing
and
and just work with people constructively
despite that some vindictive florida
counties are still punishing their own
residents like in broward county
where former gym owners jillian and mike
carnavale face
possible jail time unbelievable for not
complying with local mask
mandates jillian and mike join me now
along with their attorney corey strolla
also with us florida governor ron
desantis who's been following this story
very closely
mike i want to start with you you've
been arrested three
times over the masks
it's hard to believe isn't it laura no i
just like i can't believe this
is the united states of america when i'm
hearing this what happened
so two months after jim's reopened in
south florida
broward county came down with the
mandate saying that facial coverings
had to be worn during strenuous exercise
24 you know we filed a lawsuit against
broward county for this
24 hours after the lawsuit was filed we
were arrested
we were arrested three times in total
they seized our business they offered us
10 days in jail
we declined that and now i'm looking at
six months in prison they also arrested
jillian here as well
jillian does this seem like the country
you grew up in
definitely definitely not it barely
feels like america
uh corey uh what are the prospects here
of getting any assistance or help
well we really at this point have to
rely on governor desantis and i hate to
put it
in his lap in his executive general
counsel's lap but we've got
a political activist judge that
originally told mike and jillian before
i was ever retained
that the state was offering a diversion
program
and the judge said he was going to
personally decline it and it was the
judge that said
the only resolution he would approve is
a 10-day jail sentence for mike
in jail that is before jillian's case
was transferred in
so the way broward state charged it
mike is facing actually two
second-degree misdemeanors for a total
of 120 days in jail
and jillian is facing one for a total of
60 days in jail
oh my god for basically not having
people wear masks while exercising
that's what we're talking about this is
insanity governor desantis
uh it sounds like broward is like
thumbing their nose
at you you've been very pro reopening
getting rid of these mandates
what the heck's going on here and what
what can you do
well well it's a total overreach laura
this is exactly what we
uh ordered against last summer many many
months ago
and so i was actually just recently
briefed on this case
uh and we looked at it and so i'm glad
you have mike and jillian on
and i'm also glad to be on to be able to
say that uh effective tomorrow morning
i'm going to sign
a reprieve under my constitutional
authority
so that'll delay the case for 60 days
against both of them and then when our
clemency board meets in the coming weeks
we'll issue pardons not only for mike
and jillian
but for any floridian that may have
outstanding infractions for things like
mass
and social distancing the fact is wow
not even right to be wearing masks when
you're exercising the world health
organization
advises against it it's not healthy for
people to be doing that in the first
place
so it was a bad restriction but these
things with health should be advisory
they should not be punitive
and so we're happy to use our
constitutional authority i think they've
been treated poorly
and uh fortunately they got a governor
that cares
uh wow how does that feel to the
carnavales there you you just got your
reprieve on national television
thank you so much governor desantis we
thank you
appreciate that a lot well you
thank you ron you built your business
uh with this literally your sweat and
governor i know you've seen this all
across the state
small business owners uh american native
born
uh individuals coming here as immigrants
they work their tail off for these
businesses
and then they're they lose everything
because of a mask mandate
yeah well it's not right and uh and
obviously we're gonna be able
yeah we lost the governor but that
that i've got to say was wild
uh the carnivales did not know that that
reprieve
was coming the clemency board will meet
and
jillian uh police say that your arrest
by the way
uh on august 7th they say was warranted
because you brought workout equipment
outside
wait a second knowing what we know about
outdoor spread now
if this is absurd they rescued you for
something that is not dangerous
and that is healthy to be outside
exercising you're arrested for that
i don't even know that until i just saw
that
that's correct i was arrested outside of
my closed business
during a peaceful protest
corey uh you've represented a lot of
people we're looking at the video now
nice barbells uh looking at looking at
the video now
this this is these all these judges
who've done this
all these politicians who've had who've
tolerated this
and who've advocated this they've all
got to be thrown out of
office i mean this is such an overreach
it's sickening
i i can't agree more and to say that
that my client belonged in jail
for something that was actually taken
back when broward finally did realize
don't have to wear a mask while
exercising and you have a judge that
wants to put them in jail
when the state was ready to possibly
throw out the case is is ridiculous so
he's political activists all right
judges need to be removed
yeah we have final words do we have the
governor back governor you're back
uh final words on what what what you
will no longer tolerate we got 20
seconds in this state
no fines no penalties we got to move
forward as a state we are the oasis of
freedom
that's why florida's doing well so let's
build off that and let's not go
backwards on any of this stuff
here here fantastic segment this put me
in a really good mood
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else